hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today I'm
gonna explain a 2007 American Comedy
movie called Good Luck Chuck this movie
tells a story about a successful dentist
who is having trouble finding his true
love after being cursed by a girl the
movie begins with a group of pre
teenagers who are playing spin the
bottle at a birthday party the rules of
the game are simple
those who are chosen by the bottle have
to make out with the spinner if they
both have the same gender it's Stu's
turn but before that his friend Charlie
teaches him what he has to do to impress
The Chosen girl after Stu leaves Charlie
spins the bottle hoping that the bottle
will point at the girl with a green
dress however the bottle chooses the
goth girl named Anisha instead the girl
seems happy with the result because she
likes Charlie and they both get into the
Wardrobe Anisha begins to tease him but
Charlie keeps telling her to back off
until he is thrown off the Wardrobe in
retaliation the disappointed Anisha
curses Charlie for rejecting her wishing
that he will always fail in his future
love and the woman he dated will
eventually marry the next guy after him
the scene moves to the present day when
Charlie has now become a very successful
dentist while his best friend Stu is now
a plastic surgery doctor Charlie reveals
to Stu that he just broke up with a
beautiful woman named carol which
confuses Stu as Carol was very into him
they work in the same building however
Stu's Clinic is filled with sexy women
while the majority of Charlie's patients
are Elders after work the men attend
Charlie's ex-girlfriend Katie wedding
party during the ceremony Katie
surprisingly thanks Charlie for being
her lucky charm as she found her true
love just after breaking up with him a
woman sitting next to him suddenly
starts a conversation with Charlie and
it seems like she is attracted to him
however Charlie's eyes are locked to a
beautiful woman named cam Wexler she
coincidentally sits on an empty chair
next to Charlie and they start talking
to each other unfortunately despite her
attractiveness the woman who runs a
penguin habitat is a clumsy woman a few
moments later Charlie is approached by
the bride and they accidentally spot
Carol Charlie's ex who also has found
another lover the next day Charlie is
shocked when he enters his dental clinic
and discovers that all his patients are
young ladies while walking with Stu they
come across Carol in a bridal shop
she shows her wedding ring to them
indicating that she is getting married
Carol states that Charlie is her lucky
charm that evening Charlie returns home
and receives a lot of voice notes from
random women who desperately want to
know him
on the other hand while feeding Penguins
cam slips and subsequently gets tackled
by a penguin causing her tooth chipped
she calls Charlie and requests an
emergency treatment Charlie who at the
same time is having fun with another
woman immediately drives over to his
clinic and fixes her tooth the dentist
refuses to be paid and asks her out for
dinner in exchange however she politely
Rejects and leaves the room not long
after cam returns to Charlie after she
was unable to start her car Charlie
helps her but she accidentally leaves
her key inside the car which is locked
from inside and begs Charlie to take her
home to get the spare set of the key
after getting the key Charlie once again
asks her to go to dinner with him but
cam is not emotionally ready for that
upon arriving at his house Charlie is
very surprised when he finds his
assistant Reba has been waiting for him
she begs Charlie to sleep with her after
she found several stories about him
being a lucky charm to a single woman
Charlie refuses but Reba suddenly jumps
onto him and you know the rest in the
morning Stu encourages Chuck to accept
that he has a lucky charm and tells him
to take advantage of that by Sleeping
with more women Charlie initially
refuses as he is not that kind of man
but Stu eventually manages to convince
him saying he will be doing it to help
others find their true love after a
series of sexual intercourses the women
that he slept with one by one start to
find their lover however Charlie is not
happy and feels lonely as the women just
want to utilize his lucky charm thus he
decides to stop the service at the same
time Charlie still has feelings for Cam
and wants to fight harder to get her
love he meets cam at work and tries his
luck for the third time this time cam is
finally willing to go to dinner with the
dentist but she warns Charlie to
maintain his expectation as she only
considers him as a friend
after spending their entire night
together in a festival they finally kiss
and cam seems to have a crush on Charlie
too the following day the couple go out
on a date again and this time Charlie
has the courage to take her home while
enjoying their quality time Stu suddenly
calls the dentist and informs him that
every single woman he had slept with is
now married
Charlie becomes upset and immediately
withdraws his intention to sleep with
her as he doesn't want cam to marry
another person the next day Charlie is
still unsure about the lucky charm and
wants to put the curse to the test he
decides to date a woman named Eleanor
who stew believes will never get married
because of her appearance he even offers
her a thousand dollars so that she wants
to go out with him
the dinner goes well and they end up
getting physical while waiting for the
experiment result Charlie pretends to be
sick and requests a long-distance
relationship with Cam for some time
after a week has passed Cam feels like
Charlie is avoiding her and she states
that she can't hold it anymore she sends
him some pictures but Charlie hangs up
the phone for several reasons suddenly
Stu calls and concludes that the curse
is fake after he went out with Eleanor
and they are still not married now
Charlie is relieved and immediately
rushes to Cam's place where the couple
can finally have fun together in the
morning Charlie is shocked when he sees
Eleanor kissing a man on the TV he
becomes Furious and calls Stu who turns
out just pretended to go out with
Eleanor since that Charlie becomes
highly protective over cam as he is
afraid that she will meet her true love
he keeps calling her for no reason also
giving her a lot of Flowers and Gifts
these actions annoy Cam and she becomes
uncomfortable with Charlie's weird
Behavior one day Charlie visits cam at
work and prepares to propose to her but
suddenly he sees cam as close to someone
else named George who is actually just
Cam's hairdresser after George leaves
Charlie loses control and confronts the
man beating him in front of the visitors
fed up with his strange Behavior cam
decides to break up with the dentist
Charlie is devastated while talking to
Reba he accidentally sees a spinning
bottle and suddenly remembers about the
girl who hexed him Anisha he comes to
Stew and asks for his help to locate
Anisha after a long drive they
eventually arrive at her house where he
begs her to reverse the spell however
she states that there was no curse she
encourages Charlie to let cam go Charlie
still does not give up and tries to
arrange a meeting between Cam and Howard
Blaine a penguin expert Kim admires the
penguin enthusiasts relationship deepens
and Charlie just can observe from a
distance
Charlie tries hard to let cam go while
he plays a penguin game suddenly Stu
shows up announcing he is getting
married to Lara turns out that Lara
knows Cam and she informs Charlie that
she is leaving for Antarctica with
Howard Stu encourages the dentist to
fight for his love for cam if he really
loves her
Charlie rushes to the airport and buys
tickets for both available planes that
are heading to Antarctica
he pays for the tickets even though it
costs seventeen thousand dollars he runs
to the plane and finally confesses his
feelings to cam while begging her not to
go
turns out that Howard is married and she
goes to Antarctica with them too before
the plane departs Charlie gives cam a
ring box with a pebble inside it cam
calls Charlie and the couple kiss on the
plane on the other hand Anisha pulls out
a pin from a voodoo doll with Charlie's
face on it indicating that the curse is
now finally removed a year later the
couple are enjoying their time together
in Antarctica while being surrounded by
penguins
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching